oh my goodness i'm
shocked
i'm shocked i am
i am shook it hello everybody my name is
nyan i'm the black female engineer i
provide content for you and aspiring
software engineers and today yo i don't
know if y'all have seen
the levels dot fyi report levels.fyi
simplest way to explain it is a
glassdoor people go on there to report
their salaries their benefits and things
like that the thing is though it's
definitely
seen as the more credible or accurate
resource because they verify all the
information all the salary information
they get from actually people uploading
documents to support uh their russian
cloud they're
to support what they're saying and so
they recently came out with a 2021
salary report
saying which companies pay software
engineers the most saying which cities
pays off registers the most and oh my
goodness i'm
shocked
i'm shocked i am
i am shook it uh because okay when you
think of the companies that pay the most
for software developers i'm pretty sure
the thing that comes to your mind is
fang you know the facebook well now it's
manga but now it's not even made and now
it's
mama going with the og thing it's
facebook apple amazon netflix and google
but in general that's typically what we
think of of all the companies that pay
the most like oh you must get into fame
all the perks all the benefits of the
cash and
yet
this report
there's only one fame company
in the top five companies that paid
software engineers the best at least
entry because this is focused on entry
level on entry level software energy is
the best and i'm like where did the rest
go yeah let's just go right into it so
starting with number five
netflix netflix is reported to pay
entry-level software engineers about 226
thousand dollars of total compensation
at least for their first year now all
broken down this comes out to 217 000
of the base pay plus 35 000 worth of
stock and a twenty thousand dollar bonus
but the base like brought and that's
keep in mind this is number five like
can you imagine number one but anyway
now i'm sure i don't need to go into
that much about what netflix is you know
the streaming company they're based in
california and oh my goodness when i
looked at their benefits i
they were i think my favorite in terms
of the benefits they gave their
developers so their benefits include but
are not limited to free breakfast and
lunch every single day a 200 match in
donations and so if you donate to some
cause some charity they will match 200
so you donate 5 000 they'll donate 10.
and this is up to 20 000 but that itself
blew my mind they also have unlimited
pto and they have maternity and
paternity leave of one
year one year paid paid my job and they
also have a transportation allowance
with uber and lyft fully covered i don't
know if that's to go to the office only
and come home or if it's also like i'm
trying to go to the club and
need this left so i don't know about
that if you work at netflix please let
me know in the comments below but yeah i
really really loved just those benefits
and this is really interesting because
netflix for the longest time only hired
senior engineers and up but recently
they started hiring more new graduates
and so this is the comp and everything
for new graduates and so yeah keep them
on your mind number four stripe now
broken down their compensation comes to
a 132 000 base with a 75 000
in stock and then 27 000
of bonus so for those of you who may not
know stripe is an irish american
financial service software company and
so if you've ever tried or if you
currently run your own business and
whatnot you likely have heard of stripe
because they make it super easy and
simple i feel like i'm in an ad
they make it super easy and simple to
engage in transactions with like to me
not like that huge of a fee
um because i use tripe as well and i
really love i i personally love them i
love their dashboard i love the way they
go about displaying information and just
making it so easy to
get paid as an entrepreneur so i really
like stripe and their benefits were also
a big favorite of mine
for some reason i don't know why the
idea of maternity paternity why that's
so important to me for right where i am
right now but i have been like straight
up just like a quick little change
straight up in uh like college and when
i interview for companies and everything
i would bring up those subjects like hey
i see that your paternity it's like it's
not a given it's like they have to
request it and maybe they'll get denied
and then maternity is only like eight
weeks like what's up with that like i'm
a person who have i've always cared
about that from just a
right and wrong standpoint you know what
i mean like there's just certain things
that i feel like are right and are wrong
and even though it doesn't apply to me
right now or ever
i care about it so yes all to say their
fraternity and maternity leave is pretty
good as well theirs is 16 weeks
maternity and fraternity so i do like
that it's the same for both because
that's another thing i don't like when
there's one another one together on top
of that they offer free breakfast lunch
and dinner and this was like huge to me
250 dollars worth of allowance for
fitness gym and just wellness
initiatives they also offer free therapy
for up to 20 sessions which
huge huge huge like
yes please like that's amazing and i
love that they do that i don't know if
it's
how it's divided up if it's 20 and
that's it if it's 20 a year 20 quarterly
i don't know but the fact that it's
there in 20 is a good amount like that's
one almost every two weeks if you do the
whole year that's pretty good to me and
so i love that they offer that they have
a 4.0 rating and looking at their job
listings and whatnot they have a nice
amount of listings available right now i
haven't seen listings for new developers
all of them seem to be more like two
plus three plus years but come the late
summer fall you can definitely see more
of that roll out and so keep in mind
keep that in mind third on the list we
have roblox now roblox is an online
gaming platform that allows users to
program games and also play games
developed by other users which is really
really cool and they pay their new
developers 233
of total compensation for at least like
year one it comes out to 144 thousand
dollars of base 60 000 of stock and 24
000 of bonus pay like netflix and stripe
they also offer free lunch but something
different is they offer unlimited pto
now here's the thing
unlimited pto
is something that is very much like good
or bad depending on the company you work
for i don't know how roblox does this on
the i please know what i'm about to say
about unlimited pto has nothing to do
with them it's just considerations to
make the thing is with unlimited pto i
don't want to name the company
um
it's
pretty much the biggest company you know
you'll i've said it like three times
already in this video
they from my understanding used to offer
unlimited pto
but then they ended up taking it back
and offering like a finite amount and
the reason for that was because when
they started offering unlimited pto they
saw that less people took it which makes
so much sense to me like me personally i
would be less inclined to take it if i
know that
something is about to run out and i have
21 days use it or lose it i will use all
21 days i'll use all 80 days whatever
number you give me i will use all of
them
oh i don't want to get demonetized
but yeah i'll say i will use them if
it's unlimited
i don't know what it is now i
wouldn't use them as much because i feel
it's like oh well now is choosing to do
x y and z when before it was in my
choice before it was like yo like
they're telling me i need to take the
dates off so goodbye i'm going to
but now it's like okay goodbye
i don't know so that's my unlimited pto
but that being said it has a lot to do
with the culture of the company the
culture of the company it's their
responsibility to make sure that you
know that it is okay and welcome to take
time off and so i hope roblox is one of
those companies if you ever interview
for them or any other company that
offers unlimited pto make sure you talk
about that and you get clear on their
stance on that not from the managers and
whatnot but talk try to talk to the
people who are actually working uh like
who your co-workers would be so yeah
just a quick side bit on unlimited pto
but yes they offered they also offer
laundry and gym on site which is i
believe this watch netflix and tribe
also offered but of all their benefits i
that was like the least exciting ones i
didn't mention it they have a 4.3 rating
on glassdoor and it looks like 88
according to the surveys i saw and
whatnot 88 of people do recommend
working there so that's definitely
something to keep in mind i didn't see
any entry-level jobs out right now to
apply to but again that's another one to
keep on your list and as the months will
buy and whatnot then
really make sure you have those alerts
on second to last we have bots boss
offers total compensation of two hundred
and thirty six thousand dollars zola's
with 54 000 being stock compensation and
then five thousand dollars being the
bonus box is a california-based company
that offers cloud-based content
management their focus is really
providing collaboration and file sharing
tools for companies and so not anything
like blitz and glam in my opinion but
shoot for 236 dollars i might they have
a 4.5 rating on glass door and 92
of workers recommend working there and
so that's not a small number and at the
end of the day i want to like where i
work i want to be in a place where
people are happy to be in because it's a
job and it's just
it's just a job
it's a job that's affording me a certain
lifestyle but
if i'm sad crying on my reader work i
don't know i don't know that's
and really in terms of their benefits
there wasn't too much listed i don't
know if it's because they don't offer
anything flashy or if it's simply
because
they just don't advertise it but really
the biggest thing i saw which is still
kind of iffy they offer remote work but
i don't know if that's 100 of the time
forever now or if it's just right now or
if it's going to turn into a hybrid or
whatnot but yeah in terms of
benefits and just perks i couldn't find
too much there but i mean the cash i'll
buy my own gym membership with 236
thousand dollars so and then last but
certainly
not least we have two
sigma that was the company levels fyi
said was the best paying company to
entry level software engineers
at
000 of that being the base pay and 80
000 of that being the bonus so two sigma
all in all is in new york city based
hedge fund company that uses things like
ai and machine learning and distributed
computing to figure out the best trading
strategies and so this is something that
would for sure be very
algorithmic
heavy
algorithmically heavy
sure we'll go with it and so that's
something you're not too confident in
and do like really just like don't like
in general then this may not be the
company for you but if that sounds like
the move for you then let me keep on
going they offered pretty much the
standard type of benefits like standard
in the tech world with 20 days pto
on-site laundry transportations type ins
but the biggest thing that like stood
out to me was their 20 thousand dollar
relocation stipend keep in mind i don't
know if this is validated i don't know
if this relocations type in is for
straight up anybody who moves from
somewhere else wanting to move to that
city
or if it's based on a calculation of
some sort like is it 20 000 cash or is
it i don't know but that is something
that made my ears break up a little bit
because moving is not fun but for twenty
thousand dollars it will be it can be i
can
i can figure it out they currently have
a glass door rating of 4.5 and so like
all of these ratings are out of five and
all of these companies have been four
and above so definitely not something to
like laugh at or to overlook in terms of
open positions i did find like one
position open for new grads but
i'm not sure if it's still open because
it was like via the third party site and
i couldn't find it on their site on
their site they do have many full stack
and just other engineering positions for
people with two plus years experience
and so
there we go y'all like oh my gosh this
is what
like a hundred
and forty
did i say 100 i meant a million like
a million plus like a million
two hundred thousand dollars worth of
compensation in this list of five
companies like oh my goodness for one
year like oh my goodness but yes there
we go after talking about all of this
which companies are you leaning towards
like which one would you want i'll tell
you mine if you tell me yours i'll tell
you mine in the comments below so check
those out but yes there we go
this was fun y'all i'll see you next
week bye y'all